alors il y avait sur 12 sortant en
franche comté il y avait huit députés de
droite jusqu'à ce soir enfin même
jusqu'à la semaine prochaine
la droite résiste à l'est pas emporter
tout à fait par la vague de la
république en marche mais la droite et
quand en fort recul
vous payez la présidentielle vous payez
la campagne et les polémiques autour de
françois fillon je pense pas qu'on paye
les polémiques autour de françois fillon
on paye surtout le climat
divisés les électeurs étaient divisés
pour les présidentielles on le voyait
sur le terrain il y avait vraiment 4,4
partie des français qui était quand même
bien installés dans des positions qui
étaient très différentes aujourd'hui par
là avec le maire de saint vite s'ils
n'avaient pas fait un certain nombre de
pour cent et bien je serai au deuxième
tour 5,3 est à 14 7 en or 14 2 donc je
serai au même niveau que les
républicains sur au national ce serait à
peu près le même score
merci beaucoup françoise branger ont pas